yeah yeah
good morning hi everybody
oh there we go on this morning all right
looks like we're four four to two it's
interesting uh spot around the table but
uh never mind thank you for being here
so late in the season
um
obviously the most critical thing today
was we had planned for the majority of
the meeting to be focused on the annual
report
is the paper has already picked up
that's not going to happen today but we
do need to have a short discussion about
where we're at what's that annual uh the
annual report and our audit opinion and
we will do so and do course but the
equally very good and important items on
the rest of the paper so clear thank you
to you and to your staff for preparing
what is our first meeting I think I'm
right and see I don't think I've been
doing any other risk committee risk and
Assurance media the the side of the the
tronium our first meeting so welcome
everybody uh Tom I think you're the
newest one here welcome to it I know
Grant's also we're going to accept an
apology from him but welcome to the
meeting as well it's great to have you
here too and um and everybody else
welcome back it's good to have you here
probably just moved to the
um agenda please clearly I think
everybody'd be well aware that we live
stream
um in fact uh it's remiss of me not to
welcome those that may be watching um by
way of live stream as well I presume by
the way malavika we have no counselors
um live streaming okay thank you
um
uh so look apologies do we have
apologies um Tom you mentioned Grant is
an apology yeah Leslie you're here with
us for the first hour
are there any any other matters we need
tonight
there aren't you at my you're my son at
Arms in terms of time keeping you've
told me I'm going to do this fast but uh
no you told me
I just copped an eyebrow okay I'll move
from the chair that we accepted the
signal thanks Darren I'll put the motion
all those in favor please say aye aye
thank you very much
uh Declarations of Interest has any
matter
um in front of us uh that we need that
we should note any interests
yes Ross
uh Chia should just note when we do come
to the annual report that I have a staff
member that has been subcontracted to
ICC since late November to assist yeah I
take it you see no reason that you
shouldn't take part in the conversation
on the oil
I'd appreciate it if you could so um I'm
comfortable with that Ross Ross raised
it with me last night and I said I was
comfortable
at the involvement of his firm in a part
of the annual report wasn't going to buy
you from participation in the meeting
g'day Ria how are you welcome sorry my
Mickey Mouse work said it was 8 30. your
watch is probably more likely to be
correct than mine so so well done
and welcome to the media it's great to
have you here thank you
um
I haven't been informed of any public
um uh uh Forum or persons wishing to
speak I do have a a minor late item
which I think went up on um diligent
yesterday which was Michael's response
to the board of New Zealand letter
and I presume everybody has a copy I
think actually picked more by Chance the
design we do have we do have hard copies
uh handy if people would like to put
their hands on them
okay thank you very much
Evelyn welcome as well thank you no no
that's fine
oh I think we're just we I must be
getting close to Christmas I think we're
all Keen to keep our meeting going
um look there are no changes to the
agenda I propose we go through it in the
way that it's outlined
and at an appropriate stage will move
okay
oh okay
um uh sorry that we need oh so I've gone
ahead of myself sorry so in terms of the
minor load item we need to resolve
uh we receive it I'm happy to move we
receive it done thank you Darren second
thank you Tom I'll put the motion all
those in favor please say aye those
against scary thank you sorry about that
I should have noted that as a motion so
there are no changes to the agenda
um so let's deal then with the
um uh uh the open
items please so first up is the
committee Zone tombs of reference which
is the hang of an important thing to
deal with up front
I'm looking oh Michael I can if I say
Michael I'm going to get the right
person that I one way or the other
although I was looking the wrong way
welcome Michael appreciate you being
here and you're working with you've done
so far
thank you Mr chair tomorrow
um
as noted in the paper it's important
that at the start of each training and
throughout the life of a committee that
its terms of reference are reviewed to
ensure that they are up to date and
reflect the work of the committee
um
this is the terms of reference uh for
this committee that is proposed it is uh
tweaked slightly to recognize the
creation of the finance and projects uh
committee and its areas of oversight but
outside of that I don't have too much
more I need to say to that I'm happy for
any questions and um
we'll answer them as I can thank you
Michael it was an interesting read to uh
to refresh your memory about why we're
here so it's superb other questions or
comments yes Tom
um question and comment I suppose I know
that we receive a paper on the
um sifting well-being
um
and and I'm assuming that this committee
has an accountability for overseeing
um or for governing the what can that
area there's nothing in actually the
terms of reference I can see the
explicitly refers to that
that would be correct it's um it would
be considered as part of the overall
risk management but I think your point
is
um well made and fair and I would
suggest that we add a specific mention
and
for health and safety
thank you Tom I agree if you see any
other comments yes
Ross
doesn't State explicitly but I'm sure in
the terms of reference that we developed
last time that we ensured in prep in
terms of good governance that the
chairperson was independent
yeah I just understand I don't know
quite how the the agenda came out but
clear quite helpfully it has given me
the last the June the June 2021s which
actually starts with what is the
committee membership which I think was a
machine part from at least the papers
they were published on diligence I
presume that will be repeated at the
front of it which should pick up the
fact uh you'll get Point roster yeah so
it's already listed in the governance
statement yeah uh with the names of all
the members of the committee this comes
from the governance them and the
allegations we just don't
brand Okay click on it thank you I just
think in terms of the Standalone in
terms of reference I appreciate the
relationship with the government
statement but I think I take on board
Ross this morning you know the comments
folk would like to make
yes snobby
um right raise it sorry raise this last
term about the volume of work that's
coming through this committee I think
one of those mainly in about five hours
and just wonder whether somewhere along
the line we need to reflect that
the word risk is is a very subjective
term and I mean everything you do in
Council has some degree of risk and
doesn't matter what you look at it it's
all about risk attached to it and
whether we need to have going forward
some sort of appetite for sitting
benchmarks
or understandings of
what level of risk that we don't need to
bring to this committee as opposed to
Bringing everything it just seemed we
were doubling up everywhere and one of
the options that I'd thought about was
whether the chairs of the other
committees at the end of dealing with
any particular issue could then say this
has a degree of risk that needs to go to
the
um the risk Insurance committee as
opposed and to maybe no it doesn't have
have that I just think it would keep out
some of the stuff that we were getting I
mean this became the longest meeting we
had for I mean not just the five hour
one but it just seems to be the Longs we
have right through the program
um
appreciate that um it is a thing I've
seen you know that might be the chair
rather than necessarily the role of the
committee so I'm I'd take the advice on
that oh look um Nobby it was useful to
go as I said to go back through this
might I say Michael even to consider 2E
which is what we should be discussing
with the external auditor after the
audit
um and uh I didn't know whether in fact
we should be so prescriptive
um because I'm not certain that actually
happens
um but I think more seriously
um uh uh Navi I'd be very happy to come
back to you or come back to the
committee for the next meeting yeah
actually with trying to address that
issue yep um because uh one of the
things that through the last trainium
in a sense we haven't fully addressed
this actually item four which is risk
management
and so that's really studying risk from
the process of the top down not the
bottom-up yeah and I think if we were to
look at that process we would better
manage
the risk of overlap there will always be
some form of overlay but the risk of
overlap between the role of this
committee and indeed what you do in your
uh your committees elsewhere because I
agree we don't want to to Overlay just
say on that Mr chair there I am aware
that there is a risk work stream coming
through to this committee good I will be
in the early New Year absolutely led by
Deloitte
um so that will be coming so hopefully
and if necessary again the terms of
reference should always be considered
living and we can refine that risk yeah
paragraph four from there well look um
in that case look I mean let's I look I
probably should have been should have
been aware of that Michael but let's
build off the back of that piece of work
exactly uh um being better in terms of
the role I look I think knobby and
fairness this committee partly through
my personal role as what the governance
advisor to council through the whole
Saga of the last trinium meant that the
certainly got expanded we need to I
agree have this as a as an efficient and
direct risk and Assurance committee
rather than necessarily wandering all
over the place which uh we probably
needed to last long yep is that just a
reflection of that I mean I guess what I
was suggesting is that the gatekeeper
should not be the staff that present the
report because it it's my understanding
and it's not peculiar just to this
Council but to other organizations as
well if in doubt you put it past the
risk and Assurance it makes you safe
well I think um with the chairs that
we've got that's where the gatekeeping
could possibly occur where they discuss
at the meeting I think this needs to go
forward to the risk of assurance it has
some degree of receipts above our
appetite or below the appetite which is
where you want to look at it as opposed
to expecting stuff because when you look
at the report that we get from staff
they've got a risk criteria in them and
just about everyone has got some degree
of risk and very few that we get that
don't have said and does that in turn
trigger the fact that it needs to come
here or is it just alerting the other
committees that there's some degree of
risk
going forward yeah yeah I think and I
think I I want to come back to it
because it's big
it's a big latch on to the work that the
lawyer doing yeah Michael he will just
make sure that we've got ourselves
trimmed in the right way which would be
good yeah Mike
thank you through yourself chair um just
want to remind Council their next item
on the report is actually working
through the the work plan which has got
all the reports that are planned to come
up to risk risk and Assurance they are
very much at the higher level in
relation to the reporting going forward
in the past we've had them at the low
level while we establish what the
organizational appetite is from a
council perspective
the next the next phase which Michael
alluded to was around what is the actual
risk that Council or this committee want
us to focus on
um so it will be directed from the
committee and Council staff will
obviously be working through with what
councilman has recommended leading
through that and then it will be for the
committee to finalize what what they
want to come forward and that'll be the
content within those reports so we're
not expecting a large number of
additional reports but I'll talk to that
in the next item
thank you
just a couple of other copies from me
which are more just I think work ons and
I I can sense the need for us just to to
have a more rigorous the wrong word but
some rethinking through it based on
Lobby's point I understand how we
monitor 3B again Ross and I um we're
having a quiet chat about Financial Risk
and actually how do we do that um
I realize that also relates back to
navi's point that actually we were
getting papers from essentially your
committee there and which everybody gone
through the committee and we were
reworking a second time so we need to
rethink a wee bit about how some because
Financial Risk
particularly in this form of
affordability as an actual area for us
can be looking at so to some extent we
need to think about how we carry out
some of these Michaels which is then
what reflects ultimately uh in our work
program uh look the other thing then
um uh Michael
that's right Mike Morris uh when we come
back
um uh with the Lord report and probably
this bigger piece around the uh um the
work that the committee does under
number six I would be Keen for the
committee in particularly the new
members to receive our survey
from I think the September meeting
because that is the Baseline of what
people are feeling about this committee
including the free flow checks and I
think we should have that in mind and it
should be made available to the new
members just so they can be aware of the
committee that will complete once again
Mr chair brilliant okay so I think in
the interim we can we can receive these
as a as a working document in relevant
for the committee
um uh no game the the edition of the
front end of just the committee
composition and the point that Ross made
I think is what I'm hearing at this
stage
so the recommendations are that we
receive the report and that we recommend
to council
um uh that the terms of reference being
called right on the government statement
I think we really I don't think we're
really having amendments at this stage
do we it's really just you're going to
add that'll be honor to be part of the
government statement is hurting the
member so we're ready to cancel these
being adopted as the terms of reference
I'll move that from the chair to have a
segment
thank you Darren I'll put the motion all
those in favor please say aye those
against us Kerry thank you very much
thank you Uncle Michael
let's see we're into the program
counselors and committee members
thank you for um
the report that's before you
it is based on the work work plan
of if you see in the attachment the work
plan of the previous committee
what we've tried to demonstrate in
relation to the different reports is
that we have taken the advice and
recommendation on streamlining and also
with the introduction of another
committee reallocated the work according
to the the different um
duties and requirements of each of those
committees so that that's primarily the
reason for the second page in relation
to the work plan you'll see there
there's
on on there
page
11 of bull books you have Council
reports and finance and project work
plan those two are split out from the
previous
risk and assurance
reports that were going up so they have
now been reallocated to those different
committees in Council
the risk and Assurance committee work
plan which is on page 10 of your board
board box has also been streamlined in
relation to consolidation of some of the
reports that we had split out into
different individual ones
so the likes of one that was mentioned
before in relation to health and safety
we were we previously had health and
safety cyber and uh Financial wrestle as
three separate different reports um and
when I say Finance it was the technology
Associated to it those have all been
combined into one risk management report
so it will be one of the meaty reports
in relation to the program but that is
where predominantly they have been
combined into
from a finance risk report it's
important to note we've streamlined that
in relation to All Things relating to
finance going forward linked into that
report no longer giving the quarterly
report we're focusing on the risks
Associated to finance in that report so
that will have things like procurement
sensitive expenditure related parties
Etc
good
the main aim of this and we're taking on
the feedback going through the last
trainium that there were too many
reports the main aim of this is to try
and streamline the work going through
also for my team to have a very direct
message about what to focus on in those
um in those reports coming forward
you'll see low for the first first
period our December one we we've already
got a challenge there where we're going
to have to shift our annual report one
from December
through until a new meeting which will
need to be decided in February and that
one will need to have
a additional meeting to serve that so we
don't have that listed on the schedule
leave it open to questions
thanks that's very helpful and explain
the second page which was leave me
confused given there was a 12 12
meetings anticipated I'm glad it's not
us
do we have comments for Michael on the
program thank you for that explanation
very helpful
a couple of points for me please is that
oh sorry Navi was was that new first um
just in relation to what we were
discussing in the previous paper
um so Michael it seems as though the
um General Finance reporting will go to
the finance and project committee
and so what I was suggesting is a
process that is something triggered the
chair of that committee to say hey
there's something not quite right here
that we need to have a risk Assurance
lens over it that's where they'd make
the referral as opposed to it
routinely going for a double stamp
before it gets to full counts and gets
another stamp again so that's the
mechanism I guess I was sort of alluding
to before
I think what Michael's outlining here is
is recognizing that the way we try to
deal with Finance stress previously was
cumbersome sure
um and sign attempt to streamline so
yeah
thank you any other comments for folks
just a couple of minor detail points for
me
um Michael
um
um I would like to invite holco
so we will also join us on the September
the 23rd meeting my assumption is there
might be actually November 23 my
assumption is that that's about the time
we want to adopt our annual report which
includes the group accounts
so magnet would be would be normal for
holco to report on its audit process in
core findings and indeed it's also a
chance just to update us on their risk
profile that meant hold Co you know was
coming to us in May rather than March
that would be fine on from my
perspective but I do appreciate that's a
part of that there
um
confirmation
of the internal audit program I would
love it if that can be boredom domain I
think I think just to get us onto the
financial year cycle of July to June
makes sense in which case approving the
internal audit program Pride of the
commits of the Year makes sense even
though July is a matter of days into the
new year um I think it's just
appropriate form
um
and
foreign
problematic we haven't got a we haven't
got a tick for the recommendation to
cancel that they adopt the annual report
I don't know which one you're talking
about but I think we should be ambitious
in place from in there for November 23.
we're back into the normal year
according to everybody in the sector
including
the office of the auditor general so we
should be expecting to make a
recommendation to Council in November
2023 on the next year's annual report I
appreciate that you're actually having
to try and schedule in a meeting on 20
in no in February around our current one
um that that only means and I think this
is important and I was looking for it I
might be missing it we should expect in
March
the annual audit plan Arrangements
letter whatever we want to call it these
days from the auditor
they should be disclosing to us in March
where they are going with the coming
just want to get us on back onto the
crop cycle if you're going to give it an
opinion on November 23 in March I need
to know where to go
okay we're set I'm comfortable are there
any other comments folk would like to
make
right let's move to the recommendation
please that we receive the report we
approve the work program
um I'm not going to say as amended
because those are just things keep us
going okay
um do I have a mover and a second to
please thank you rangi thank you Navi
put the motion all those in favor please
say aye oh it's against it's scary thank
you very much
right health and safety Peter thank
you
good morning Mr chairman of Clark
counselors
just like to make a couple of comments
um you'll note in the report
I've noted the difficulty we're having
in recruiting for air health and safety
positions so we currently have two
positions that are vacant that make up
our health and safety team and we are
having difficulty recruiting for those
second comment will be although I
haven't included incidences near misses
in this report
um
during the last six months we have seen
a notable increase in the number of
incidences and near misses of aggression
towards staff
whether this be in the building here in
the cab an arborist and the suburbs
trimming the tree gardeners working on
Center plots
um the parking compliance team animal
control but there is two or three
incidents has been reported weekly not
saying there's not more but we're
getting two or three reported weekly
thank you did you guys want to say Peter
that's it thank you thank you very much
okay expect questions for Peter at the
stage seriously rangi then Tom
um thanks Peter like just on your
opening page it talks about health and
safety terminology and it talks about
that near misses not actually noted by
worksafe as a as a geminology not in the
glossary on their website no it seems
weird because
um just bringing out one incident quite
a serious one was white Island where
tour Opera tourer
um the company was prosecuted
for having
um people there in the morning
completely missing the accident that
were prosecuted for what I'd see as an
EMS now if they don't have it in there
if they don't have an EMS sort of thing
in there and their whole
guidelines then
bemused by how a company could be
prosecuted you know
um considering no one knew that was kind
of erupt at the time so I was just just
um I was surprised that worksafe don't
treat near misses
um actually formally
yeah it's very unusual
I wonder whether I'm running just what
we were going here I think it's valuable
to note that perhaps websites don't have
that but the reality of it is it's I
think I could say it's accepted practice
and I defer to other members in the room
that have health and safety experience
that the concept of near misses is
actually valuable in the practice of
health and safety because of exactly the
definition that you've got here from
elsewhere which is they are they are
really important reading experiences I'm
not knocking the four years it's great
importance that we do recognize those
but it just really amuses me that that
that worksafe with all their
um sort of power that they will
um don't actually formally
seem to recognize it until later on when
it suits them
through because it's quite highly
procedural time you've got a question
it's perhaps a
question to you chip actually rather
than a question to Peter but it's become
normal practice I think for large
employers to have you know a governance
group that specifically looks at health
and safety rather than as part of its
modern risk committee
um I think it'd be true I don't know but
local government but certainly in a
private sector virtually since a health
and safety work act virtually every
board has got a health and safety
committee and and I just wonder whether
we will ever as part of this committee
um have tainted properly consider health
and safety or whether it perhaps should
be a subcommittee whether a subcommittee
should be established to look
specifically at this issue
now Tom would like to take it you're
wanting to reopen the center referencing
given your previous comment I think um I
want to look I want to that sounds like
a cheap shot like I want to um
say I I hear your point and and and
indeed agree uh that the question
becomes how does invercargill City want
to approach from a governance
perspective health and safety and I
wonder if we should readdress that after
we've had PX items Chad I was I was
suggesting that it would remain under
audit and risk perhaps would be a
subcommittee avoidant risk no I hear
yeah
um
what I say most local government it is
part of of the forward and risk
committee by the way Tom just out of out
of interest
um uh there are variations that I have
observed around the the country but
essentially it is in the you know the
way it sits here I think the question
becomes when do we need
um and probably the case is not when but
how do we have appropriate Focus I take
on board your advice let's as I say come
back to that potentially after we've had
our pH discussions thank you appreciate
that any other questions or comments
just for us uh three uh Chia Peter you
noted uh specific instances throughout
declaration and staff I just want to
know if there are any other areas that
you we need to be aware of
um in terms of health and safety that
might be risk areas or pinch points at
the moment specifically and I'm thinking
is there any increase around use of EAP
and the stress around covert and
financial issues
uh we use the Ray Ray's EAP as a support
for employees we have not seen a
noticeable increase in the last uh six
to eight months we are averaging uh one
to two unplug staff members contacting
EAP a month though
for a variety of Reason uh majority of
the cases are non-work related issues
it's not just some clarification
um
certainly most big organizations
referred to in the near Miss as being a
third party near miss that tends to
involve that
um so a good example if you drive down
the road and you're doing everything
right but somebody comes very close to
you in a vehicle
um
with the incidents um seem to be more
internal that's why most organizations
look at it so good example out as you
internally you have a situation that
with hindsight
potentially could have been dangerous or
somebody else from another work area
intervenes into your work area
um Tom race is a an interesting point
we've got an in the PE part of our our
committee meeting report from safe safe
plus
and I think if you look into that it's
um quite critical and I don't want to
get into that at this stage but it's
quite critical of what's missing at the
top end of our organization
because health and safety is a top down
not bottom-up you can do as much as you
like at the bottom but the message is
not clear at the top then it gets uh
gets off site so I don't know where we
will get to today and what part of that
we will discuss that report because it
needs to be discussed
I think um this paper Peter and I
appreciate you Ken you're being kinded
about what it is and what it isn't
um I mean this is not a paper to manage
or govern health and safety
uh croissant because obviously as you
see there isn't there isn't information
there that actually you can manage on
it's more a state or the high level and
I take it because I appreciate you doing
the hard yards and covering in fact for
positions that we have been unable to
fill yes so my assumption is that we
need to get those filled to get the
proper and partitional input
into
um shall we say enhanced or better
health and safety which would include
the nature of the reporting either this
committee or a subcommit
these two yeah so I think I think we we
are
um knobby at some level of risk here
not merely based on this report yeah
absolutely no doubting that that
actually but actually the ability for
for counselors and
um to to participate in the section of
44 duties is difficult so I think we we
should we should just acknowledge that
and I'm not that's certainly not a crack
either a clear or a Peter but just
recognizing the challenge of actually
filling those vacancies so it does raise
for me the question
um are we just vulnerable to the market
in terms of finding those positions it
seems to me one of the pivotal things
that is sitting behind all of this all
this challenge I wonder if somebody can
provide a comment or is it just the
market yeah snobby two things um
I had the fortune or Misfortune of
sitting in on the sit graduation trees
meet and to my surprise when we looked
at both Masters and degree level which
is significant levels of occupational
health and safety
no I think we were about 35 or 40
graduates out of that program
so not all of them will be here for sure
but there might there may be some
potential there to recruit but going
back to what Tom says I think
um we can sit here and look at water
under the bridge
um that's not going to achieve anything
but going forward we need to have a
subcommittee that focuses on health and
safety even if we don't have dedicated
health and safety people and that I
guess that subcommittee might be
councils that have some passions here
and some senior staff that need to be
involved and certainly without the
health and safety people that needs
involved just about all of elt because
we've we've got some issues to resolve
and then that reports to this committee
or diagnosing what the Health Report is
what we got from that independent
provider only gives us a steer forward
we've got to do something for anything
um to overcome the issues that we've got
it I've got rangi and then Darren yeah
um thanks chair look I think
um both Tom and Nobby have valid points
there for the last 12 years on Council
um we we get emails saying
um please meet at uh some particular
work site for your necessary health and
safety duties or whatever
responsibilities it's a it's a request
that some people go along to not many
people go along to and to me that seems
a very
but it doesn't seem quite the correct
way of counselors being involved in
health and safety when
um it's it's like it's almost like your
best effort to show up
um if it was assigned to a subcommittee
it would give it far more dedicated
responsibility and accountability
so I'm all in favor of it because what
I've seen over the last 12 years has
been really just something I I see as
just trying to tick a box
to keep there
thanks chair I guess conversely on on
the other hand the risk of of
um having that subcommittee of people
who are interested
um doesn't actually abdicate the
responsibility that sits with other
counselors I mean ultimately everybody
has has a duty
if some people aren't taking an interest
in
um
that needs to be to be raised with them
directly I mean ultimately there can be
a variety of reasons why
um site visits can take place I've
missed the last one because I had the
spicy cough and it was probably me
managing a bit of risk around the other
staff members and councilors
um
but I know and and Tom will be familiar
from health and safety processes with
eil and PowerNet that they were vigorous
at a director level
which is the same as as being a
counselor and it's not
just a
a process of doing a site visit
but it's actually every time you're in
the space if you notice stuff to ask
questions to engage with staff to give
them from our level down the indication
that we actually take this seriously and
getting them to understand that there is
a culture shift from how things were
before before the ACT came in so I guess
my fear is that putting it down to a
subcommittee is just signaling who's
who's truly interested in
who's not
I think I think I'd like to probably
just park the subcommittee at this stage
okay it time you've raised a really good
point and I don't think we should miss
it we should lose sight of that I think
and I think also what I'm hearing is
clearly is is councilors and I uh join
you on this a level of concern about the
challenge challenges that that are
objective that we are facing in terms of
upscaling our our response and it's
starting with the issue of of
um good work by you and I think I should
mention probably Steve I understand you
know have voluntarily picked up this on
behalf of your colleagues which is great
to deal with it but we haven't quite got
it on the footing that we that we
collectively as management and as as
governments hopeful or actually plan for
aim for I should be more more definite
about that
um which which means actually this
recruitment process is actually quite
critical
um and in a minute I don't think there's
anything common clear that could be made
on that other than actually you are
where you are into the market right Mr
chair I think that I could make a
comment and so far as and I'm sorry to
to differ with you but
um recruitment is
I I don't wish to say impossible but
um we've gone two rounds for a health
and safety manager yes and uh We've made
an offer we've been verbally accepted
and then the current employer has up
their uh rate uh we've had another
candidate and they've withdrawn when
their existing um employer has known and
has upped their rate quite frankly we're
just moving the ditches in the South
we're not paying enough to attract and
it's not that we're not paying the
market
it's that this level of job is there are
enough other good jobs elsewhere in the
country
and the sector has since I joined
Palmerston North in 2002 the sector has
talked about growing its own
but it didn't grow its own health and
safety people
so finding somebody to lead
in fact I'd go further and say finding
somebody who meets our expectations in
terms of culture and doesn't bring a
regulatory
enforcement approach but works to win
the hearts and minds of our staff
is
challenging
and so I I want to encourage you to move
away from thinking about recruitment to
thinking about how we identify the right
person or people from within our
existing compliment who can learn the
skills
in the light of attempts to recruit we
may have think of different ways of
doing it which I think it's your your
very safe advice and I don't want to get
into the trying to control recruitment
I'm just trying to recognize it at the
moment we have got a skill deficiency
which which is affecting our overall
view right I think actually I think your
hand was up first time and then I got
mummy
I think we
acknowledging that we don't have a it's
difficult to get a specialist who can
put it all together we should also
acknowledge the fact that a second
ability and Leadership actually
to to manage the health and safety
within their own teams
it's not an accountability of a safety
specialist and and we have when we the
fact that we cannot get safety
Specialists does not change the fact
that we have got that obligation to look
after our people well and when we look
at the report that we see later in the
in these reports um we have a relatively
immature Safety Management System
um so I I guess the point I'm trying to
make however it is done whether it's
done in the way that Dan's suggesting
that are done in a way that I'm
suggesting
um governance needs to be ex
Dynamic governance normally does to try
accelerate processes to to give it
enough interest that
um you know that that
um we we see the safety Association
better than perhaps STD
irrespective of recruitment actually
yeah I totally agree with Tom just see
look um
and we are slightly different to eil
which is Darren referred to because the
directors of eil are are accountable
counselors are not accountable under
health and safety so the back stops with
clear and the pcbu and so but it's
remiss of us not to support clear and
the executive leadership team
if we have um people that are schooled
enough and I've certainly done 10 years
of this work and Tom's got a huge amount
of experience as well so we could easily
sit in on that group like that to get
that overarching stuff the diagram that
Michael's got on
Peter's got on on
page 24 is actually right if you you
know you've got to have that executive
stuff top down
and so we can help with it I mean it's
too easy just to sit back and say well
the bug stops was clear and I mean I can
tell you from my experience
over that 10-year period of investing
probably every fatal accident south of
in that time
um that if we had a fatality at work and
we had the report that we got later on
in the agenda sitting in front of a
coroner we would have nowhere to hide
and the immaturity is as a life way of
putting it in the report but we've got
to do some work we can't just have a
coming back committee clear is quite
right
and Tom saw right we obligations don't
stop and start with having a recruited
specialist we don't have one we've still
got to fill the Gap and make things
happen
I agree and I think we're all agreeing
strongly about the position that we're
actually in yeah I'd like to suggest
that unless there is something new to
raise because we have other items as as
we keep alluding to in our later in our
agenda where we may want to revisit
their steps as governments we want to
take are there any new comments on this
report at this stage it's not just one
final thing and you might give some
guidance on this if there was a desire
by elected members to go down the
subcommittee line is it our shop to call
on that do we set it up was that
something that the risk and Assurance
committee would say that
I think I'd probably take Claire's
advice on that but I think if we I think
this is what I want to come I asked
could we deal with this issue after
we've dealt with the stuff in PX okay
because we need you know we have more
information that is going to come out
there sure I actually think this is an
agreement between ourselves and
management and particularly clear rather
than necessarily a command or bottom-up
or topped out I think we're all agreeing
that actually we are challenged by
health and safety and something needs to
happen and reasonably quickly
was that one of the few roles that I do
have has been able to set up committees
and so that's what it takes then I'll
get on and get that done I'm looking for
consensus but I take your point yep can
we go to the recommendations unless
there's anything else people would like
to raise please which is that we
received the report and we approve oh
that's the wrong one I've gone back too
far my apologies
um that we
received the report and we note the
summary of work Undertaker today which
I'm sorry that we haven't focused on the
on the appendices but we've had a chance
to look at those so they sit there okay
do I have a person prepared to move
these motions
thank you there do I have a signal
thank you rangi I'll put the motion all
those in favor please say aye all right
those against
Kerry thank you
right we could then move please to the
audit
my brother actually I suppose more
correctly the annual report in the
audits it isn't um
that isn't yes that's right
and fairness for this process so Michael
Patricia thank you
to the front we're in your hands
thank you cheer
near Clark and committee members and
councilors
before you have a two letters that one
is from our um
external Auditors and the other is from
myself in response to those auditors
what I think it highlights to you as you
do not have an audit opinion before you
today and you are not like to likely to
get one before Christmas
in fact we have actually started our
planning and work to try and Target in
or February as a date so we're
proactively worked with the Auditors to
change direction towards that path
what I want to do before handing over to
Patricia will give you a bit more detail
into the process of what's gone on
within the audit so you can get a bit
more understanding of the What's led to
today's events but also I want to give
you a bit of a Insight from my
perspective on
on where the audit is
changed over time in relation to this
process but also in last year as well
one of the changes that we've seen in
relation to the audit process is the
introduction of Technology into their
their process because they have
resourcing challenges that is widely
known amongst the industry but it is
also caused another headache in relation
to that
the introduction of the technology has
made a change in the approach of the
Auditors with the staff and I've noticed
it very much in relation to this this
particular process with our air staff
and I want to highlight that I haven't
really
Delta dealt to it within the letter but
I have dealt with the outcome of it
within the letter
the primary outcome of it is we have had
a change in the way communication is
occurring within the audit process
we are finding that the Auditors are not
communicating with the staff directly as
happened when they were physically on
site or when they had to deal with it in
a manual way
the reason being is they they have
multiple resources potentially around
australasia we did have people from
Australia on this one
and their communication planner channel
is straight through the technical portal
this is creating a headache in relation
to what they deem a misstatement because
the misstatement in some of them are
recorded as things where they've said
this item still needs to be done or
there is a space here or what some of
the other primary examples that I've
looked at is this work this work is
still outstanding
they're all sort of things that you
would have had a discussion with the
order to on a one-on-one basis and that
would not have ended up being a
misstatement from that perspective so
you're seeing a higher volume from that
perspective
classic example of this is when we had
the Auditors on site and I don't think I
saw I probably saw the order two of the
Auditors travel the the building in that
whole time
they spent their time actually still
working through the same digital
platform even though they had located
themselves in their building
to me that is a big downside of having
the technology and something that I
think back to audit NZ they need to
think about and work forward on
what are the highlights for me from the
audit um well actually I would reverse
that and say low lights because I do see
it as a um
a major issue in relation to the order
and a bit of the breakdown
is the communication between myself and
the audit director has not been at the
highest of levels
the example would be I think the mirror
has had more one-on-one communication
with the audit director than I have had
and he's had one conversation
that should highlight how many I've had
the only audit uh one-on-one
conversations I've had were pre-audit in
relation to something not relating
directly to the plan of the audit
having stated that we have had a number
of governance meetings and I I know we
have
um one of the independent members of the
committee is going to give us an uptake
in relation to those governments so I
won't dwell on that too much but I have
highlighted in the report one particular
governance meeting which was on the 24th
of November uh which I did ask a very
pointed question and that question was
very direct which is was there anything
that would give us cause to not meet the
20th December at which stage I was told
nothing
and I think I've also highlighted that
all the matters that were raised in the
audit comments should have been known
it took nine days to find out that that
was not the case and it was not relayed
to the governance board or to myself I
heard second hand in relation to that
from my operations team
okay
that illustrates what I'm talking about
with the technology and the
communications breakdown and I think
they need to find a way through that we
are here to help and support and we're
here to work through that we want the
audits to be successful as much as
probably they do because I think they do
have a resourcing challenge as do we
I've Illustrated in the report work
resourcing challenges we have and I
won't go into that any further
but I won't do now is hand over to
Patricia who will take you through some
of the more finer detail I think it is
important normally I wouldn't go into
the detail in a meeting like this but I
think given the context some of the new
committee members and councilors
probably need to understand the process
that local government audits have to go
through to understand and appreciate the
challenges that we've got in relation to
this order
dude
thanks Michael
um sit the same the audit is not a short
one it's approximately six weeks of
field work at after year end with a week
typically in June I'd prefer March but
typically June
um they are auditing more than
financials they will audit every word
that is within the inner in a report
document but they spend significant
amount of time on auditing a performance
against the levels of service
and this is all under the thing which um
the chair will understand
that the public sector audits are
different from a private sector audit
they're very much focused on ensuring
that there is credibility within the
public sector
so that they are looking at things in a
much different lens which requires a lot
more information and a lot more work
you also need to recall that the council
does not have a choice on its auditor
the officer the auditor general appoints
an auditor we also do not have a choice
of the cost the cost is determined by
the office of the auditor general
in relation to this year's audit the
field work began on began on the 31st of
October there has been 13 Auditors at
last count excluding the director that
have been rolling in and out between one
and three weeks at a time there has also
been two managers and one assistant
manager
that's actually twice the size of my
finance team working on them if not
three times
so there is a large Quantum of
information
the information requests have been
extensive initially they asked for 121
different information requests which we
had provided the bulk by the time they
started as of Monday There's 248
information requests sitting on their
online tool
um
127 being added during the audit
only 10 are still sitting with us to
answer
and there's 29 of those that we're
waiting for audit to consider
and the resource plan for the audit was
never fully shared with us operationally
I would get the resource for the next
week on a Thursday afternoon and the
focus here is that they would be looking
at including whether an auditor was
rolling off the audit in the next week
so we could prioritize the queries over
everyone else's
to close out sections so we lacked that
big picture which now means that it
became very clear in the operational
meeting which they said they were unable
to sign off at that they hadn't actually
started some sections at all yet
and that is still the case today
it also makes it incredibly damn
difficult to upwards manage the audit
which is typical in both private and
public sector audits that the client
will be doing some upwards management
so
the resourcing issues Michael's already
talked about and it's well known with
the Border closures have probably
actually hampered it more
now the board is reopening we are seeing
some new stuff coming into the audit New
Zealand and we're working with those
we also are expecting that next year we
will return to a 31 October signing date
and ccos at 31 at 30 September
so we will have to do things much sooner
the significant resourcing issue for my
side was that they didn't necessarily
put the right sections in the right
order
the section because we did a full
revaluation this year of all our assets
that requires third party input into the
audit those weren't done up front
and there wasn't good communication with
those third parties to say this is when
audit this is when we need to do the
audit and as a result they've been
impacted by both covered and other work
requirements that meant they haven't
been able to return the information in
the same level as what audit would like
there was a request of an external
valuer to turn around questions in 24
hours
there is also an external value where
there has not had any questions raised
of them yet and that will happen in late
January
what Michael said about the technology I
would call it email audit by email
um rather than audit by phone call or
even a quick in our Zoom meeting
the misstatements I will agree are
significant but having been through the
list multiple times they do include the
bits we're including we will sign on the
20th of December that's been raised as a
misstatement because that still had to
be confirmed
so there are small things formatting
spelling mistakes
that haven't been picked up by
spellcheck and those sorts of things
but probably the bigger delay is
actually the technical issues that came
through there are two significant
technical issues outstanding one has now
been
um
coming
to they're coming up from out of the
ichl group
one has now been cleared so we're
working through that one with audit so
as at 31 December the only outstanding
audits will be ICC group and ichl group
um there's been the need for significant
for an external expert to provide report
a report
in order to clear an issue
and that's what's taking the time
and was the reason for the delay
however
we have been working proactively to try
and speed that up and hence why we've
come to a
mid-February mid to late February
signing date but clearing those points
but once we had the issues not
necessarily at the technical
then something will always come up
during an audit it's actually more in
the day-to-day management of the audit
that's been the real issue for us
that's it that's it thank you radio
appreciate it sorry I was I was I
thought there was a concluding statement
or something like I wanted to invite
Ross to just quickly note his
perspective
um uh at the time that we
had challenges with the priority we
agreed that we'd grip up as a committee
and support and Ross and I have met
monthly generally with the Auditors so
Ross I'm interested in your perspective
please
thank you Bruce
um as you say I don't want to religate
any past issues for 2021 but given it
was a post balance date issue then that
we were dealing with and some are now
post balance date issues again
um that causes me some angst on its own
um but we did put in place a process
after
the 2021 sign off where Bruce and I met
with the audit director to
[Music]
clearly spell out our expectations going
forward and hear any grievances we had
in respect of that
so we stepped outside our governance
role and we did meet monthly uh with
both our finance team and the audit
senior audit team
there were quite a number of occasions
that I chaired that meeting when Bruce
was not available
and the points we covered were to ensure
that was adequate resource on both sides
that we identified any pinch points
we noted any technical issues
we noted any group issues
and we noted timeliness
and I support you know Michael's
response given that on that 24th of
November meeting there were no major
issues identified
the only provider we had at that stage
was if either team suffered sickness via
covered and we
they knew we we hadn't had an issue
um that point was raised at the
subsequent meeting
um when audits were giving their reasons
for delay and they expanded on that and
we did pull them and I did pull them
into line
um saying that the only reason they gave
was that they couldn't deliver was if
covert affected their team
um
we a note in terms of that it should be
well planned in advance you plan any job
well in advance and you allow extra
hours in that plan because no audit runs
smoothly especially for an organization
of this size and I would suggest any
other local Authority
foreign
so yes I also felt blindsided by the by
the decision and I was certainly
disappointed in the way it was
communicated
um and as I said it's pretty obvious
obvious that I believe the order New
Zealand planning uh was inadequate
now I've worked in public practice as a
partner all my career in over 27 years
as a partner and my clients expectations
need to be met if I fail maybe they give
me another chance
um but as you say in our case we don't
have another provider that we are able
to go to
um
also note in terms of order in the
technology that is quite common
um the process now and I know our client
major clients and public companies that
we act for uh when the audit team come
in they do sit in the boardroom with
their laptops in that tool they do in
their interaction as
um and I'm also you know I think that is
a wider
um
let's see
the other
anecdotally I understand that there are
up to 20 local authorities that dates
have been pushed out I know I have hit
um spoken to two and what we need to
understand is either there are
substantive issues that need addressed
or if it's just a timeliness and
resource issue
I'll suggest in terms of
local authorities end the dates in the
in the um
pressure all of New Zealand's under that
only a joint submission of the chief
Executives and mayors of the local
authorities is going to affect any
change
um and make us heard I don't think
little of the cargo on its own is going
to be able to do that
and perhaps I'll leave it there cheer
and we can respond after counselors
questions
thank you Ross appreciate that
appreciate your comments okay so we have
the issue
um by the way one one group that isn't
here is the Auditors and I want to
reflect a small involvement that they
rang me direct to explain the letter
that was coming through that we have on
our agenda paper and it seemed at that
stage that the stage had been set uh
that we weren't going to Independent on
the 20th and that indeed in my view and
it will put and I'm prefacing here what
I'm suggesting in terms of a resolution
we will need quite frankly sit down with
audit New Zealand
is an accountability exercise and thresh
this out we're not going to achieve that
today actually I think the critical
thing is that um I think for the first
time uh Patricia we actually have a
defined planned with key issues to get
us to the actual date of somewhere in
February 23 which is useful and I'm
appreciative that we should allow you
folk to focus on that at this stage
so with those comments are there any
comments Tom rangi
and then Darren
sure we we all know that
um
Audits and particularly I think of you
know
innocent associated with Ukraine because
you have to look at much broader
um areas uh are very iterative
affairs you know I I think the Lehman
might imagine some in order to come in
and looking at your books and you know
and of course being oh no it's not like
that there's constant iteration and it
needs to be extremely good communication
and it seems to be clear that
um that is not cut
um I I was quite shocked actually when I
read
a comment from Mr Olsen and it appeared
in stuff so I'm not quite sure where
they got it from but if I can risk read
it Orson acknowledge 20 2021 was
extraordinary because of an auditor
shortage and you had to prioritize work
unfortunately Council deadlines were at
the end of the queue he said
would have ended occurred and I mean
that's good to be completely
unacceptable and and I I know that you
know we we are certainly not Robinson
cruso and having problems with other New
Zealand
um and I know the other organizations
including you know government
organizations have moved away from
Modern New Zealand because you simply do
not have the resources to to do the work
and I think that's acknowledged even the
Mr Lawson's comment
um so I I I would certainly encourage
you know the work that you've described
cheer and and perhaps with the mayor
um and looking at whether there is an
alternative to audit New Zealand that we
could use as other organizations have
um because I think anyone wants to see
we are at the end of the queue well it's
completely unacceptable because I don't
think your legal obligations are any
different other than any other
company
uh this will cause us to breach Our
obligation to report by 31 percent
so we have we we are not meeting our
legal responsibility exactly
so I think so as as Governors I think
you know we we simply cannot accept that
and I know the other organizations
including organizations have been a
director of who've moved away from
Modern New Zealand exactly for that
reason
okay uh sorry Mark you want to make a
comment on this
it's just in response to the statement
from the auditor around being at the end
of the queue it's worth Council
reflecting on uh which
um same auditor and Derek um presented
to us in 2021 and explained that process
where
the commercials are at at the Forefront
in relation to a lot of the audits I
mean their deadlines then it goes down
to
um the a lot of the trusts and
subsidiaries from that perspective then
it moves on to because they've got
other deadlines that they need to meet
statutory deadlines as well uh then from
when it gets to local government it then
moves to the larger councils and note
some of those larger councils have only
just signed off this month and they
should have been closer to September
so the pressure is then compounded and
then towards the end of that they start
which they tell us they don't do but
they start coming down the country with
the smaller councils and you'll see a
lot of the smaller councils further up
the council we're getting their signed
off pre-Christmas so they do have an
approach of coming down slightly through
the uh
through the country so that's where the
comment is we're at the end of the queue
um it is literally the end of the audit
queue in relation to the annual calendar
from there for Speed well so it's an
honest comment but it's a very shocking
one
running
um look after reading both the letters
um and thanks for Michael's reply
um the key part is that accumulation of
matters and the 24th of November day now
at what stage
um
do you say we're just feeding our heads
again against the brick wall dealing
with the people we're dealing with and
we jump on a plane and fly to Wellington
and actually speak to someone at the top
of the food chain I've just had a look
at the hierarchy of born in New Zealand
and at what stage do you do that if you
if you've got a um a tradesperson
working in your house and they do an
absolute crap job
and you're not happy you ring the owner
of the company
um so I do we you know that's the way
I've always done things myself if you
have a problem and you're not getting
anywhere uh what what sort of
responsibilities do the uh Chief
executives
of audit New Zealand have
I mean are they accountable as well or
do they just get paid a lot
ruggie I would suspect
um that in the end of this there will be
communication with supporting New
Zealand uh and I would
um
I would suggest to you that we will get
good representation from the senior
ranks of War at New Zealand over the
concerns that we have so that is a plan
yep right I want to reflect there is a
level of accountability that has to
happen over this
occur once we've got the order done and
we've got to get the order done right
okay and and
what is concurrently or with it we will
have to have a discussion around the
accountability and the service that has
or has not been provided right and I'm
sure I'm confident that will include
more than the director
thank you Darren
thanks chair
um it would be fair to say that there
was a strangled groan of exasperation
that I emitted when I um
read the not completely unexpected email
telling us that it was unlikely to be
um signed off today
and that harks back to our experience
last year
um
and I recall being cautioned about
sliding the professionalism of an
auditor
but my concern is around the process and
if I were honest watching what's been
going on with other councils for us to
be in this position is actually no great
surprise nor I think is it um
thank you
is it actually our fault as is quite
contrary to Mr Olsen's letter
I think the one thing that that really
stands out is the fact that there have
been these regular meetings
and that within the space of less than a
month we go from there being no issues
to
here's two pages of them
and that's just not acceptable
and questionable
um you know there should be some
traffic-like system of of issues being
raised and if there was
a series of things that had already been
identified that were considered to be
Works in progress fine if they should
have been an Amber then then they should
have been but they weren't and we've
gone straight to red
um as frustrating as it is I know that
the resolution of it is also not
straightforward
um I know Ross's comments with interest
around the the
change I guess and and work habit across
many sectors
um not just audit and accounting but
there is a a tendency now to
um
communicate in a one-way manner
rather than two-way instant
communication and let alone the the
benefit that you can get from the
non-verbal communication of even a zoom
rather than just banging off an email an
email should be the last result there's
nothing like a phone call and and the
the best you can have is face to face
and we will look forward to that
opportunity in the new year but as a
sector and it seems to be our issue
that's the concern and it's a
sector-wide response I think that
we need to to signal with
um with lgnz talk to our other uh local
government Partners from this region and
go how many of us are in this position
um this is not our fault really we're
we're the ones who get named in
Parliament
bearing in mind that we've been under a
Dia Spotlight for the last couple of
years
if there was something that we had done
wrong we would own it
and rectified that's just just what we
do but as a sector we need to be going
to
the minister and saying
this isn't acceptable
and there needs to be some
uh change in in the structure of the
audit process either with how
the office of the auditor general deals
with us or how their resource to how we
can go out and Source it are we able to
go private to um
accredited Auditors bearing in mind that
as Patricia said there are many more
things than just Financial that are
being looked at
but I think it's a sector-wide approach
to resolving the issues that's going to
get us the the best outcome that as far
as we sit with this it is what it is and
we've just got to write it out noting
the impact that it has on staff noting
the impact that it had on staff last
time and the cost to us
not just Financial but um we lost people
um but also the effect that it has on
our annual plan process
because we only have limited staff
and the work that they'd be doing for us
on the annual plan is now going to be
still tied up with completing this order
and that's
hugely frustrating as well
so I guess
I understand and I'm not surprised at
the position that we're in but I think
the only way to to get change because
otherwise this is just going to happen
again next year no matter what we put
down on paper
uh is to have a sector-wide response
thank you thank you right can we move to
the oh maybe
um yeah look on
I'm not sure that going through lgnt
will help us um
I think we just need to make a stand
ourselves
so I'm quite heavy as rangi suggested to
go in front somebody up with a range of
issues look I I had a meeting with Derek
directly one-on-one in my office
um around these dates and I was very
specific with him I said then will we
get to the 20th Yep yep it's all looking
good any issues no no it's all fine
um I said look just be mindful I will
not sign after the 20th I'm not going to
repeat what happened last year as Deputy
Mayor raced into an office
I think on the 24th of December and
signed at 5 PM or five to five right
before the deadline and I didn't know
what to sign well I knew what a sign but
I didn't know what amendments had gone
on in the preceding two or three days
and I said I just wouldn't go down that
track again he said oh well you know you
could end up reporting to be reported in
Parliament I said well so be it
um yeah she's not an Aaron so I just
find this whole letter for her just a
butt covering exercise and it needs to
be challenged and we can't tip that
around using as others have said we'll
just send it down the same path again
next year but we've been over backwards
we've got resourcing issues as well but
you know one manager two assistant
managers in 13 orders is over before the
period is not good
um
and even by technology as opposed to
face to face
as guaranteed it's not good either
um he didn't alert us to anything in
that meeting I had I'm sure it's around
about the seventh but I will check the
date he specifically came in to see me
not the other way around
um
yeah I think it's just a fast so using
your wider hat I understand that Gore
and SDC have deloittees
uh are they getting through the process
when signed off
so is this a super wide issues or is
this an order to New Zealand um uh
environment telephone have been signed
off by Deloitte South industry or not
because of the resourcing challenges and
in order to generalize Southland
District to change order to
um in October to Deloitte but because of
their resourcing situation that couldn't
that won't be signed off until next year
so are they currently deloittees they
have moved towards yes I mean when I'm
trying to sift out is this an audit New
Zealand issue or is it because I've had
feedback as well that the resourcing
issues right across the segment
I would I mean I'm conscious as I said I
would like uh what did New Zealand to
stand on their own two feet in front of
us and talk to their their issues I
think I think it's only fear in the
final analysis I think it's good that
through this public meeting they are
aware that we are very unhappy
um uh and they will describe their
resourcing challenges but I do want to
say that yes I have had enough uh
messages given directly in the sector
heard and being party to where the
resourcing challenges across all
Auditors has been challenging but
particularly focused around ordering
Zone
okay how do we just move to the
resolutions please I think we've had a
reasonable crack
and I just wonder if
um these amended uh resolutions which uh
prepared yesterday uh would satisfy us
as a means of going forward so firstly
we received the report
that we note the letter from New Zealand
and Management's response the last
phrase is what I've added and the rest
is what I've added
that we record our disappointment plan
completion of the external reporting
commitments cannot be met by the
secretary reporting deadline of 31
December
2022 I think it's important we recognize
that this will constitute a statutory
breach
the committee notes that management is
Expediting completion of the annual
report and receive your opinion by the
end of February 2023.
that's what we're working to and
um that's the deadline
that the committee asked the independent
chair and member
that's Ross and I to respond to what it
was on and by the way that should be the
overag not the Assembly of God
with the committee's concerns regarding
the litter and the and Management's
response
in that the council notes that the
committee will meet with or New Zealand
to discuss the issues outlined in their
letter including Management's response
and we'll report back to
Council
23.
[Music]
may ask a question to you sorry yeah
okay
foreign
I did actually by the way and it just
Claire's asked me about my intention of
number six
um I mean I think quite frankly the way
this will work out there will be a need
for Ross and I and probably you Nobby
and I dear say it is
some of management clear and Michael
producer to meet directly with audit New
Zealand to discuss this
okay but I also think that actually the
committee should also meet with the
audit director we have to
um but I um uh um and when that's going
to happen probably roughly the same time
we get the opinion because theorem is
going to be here
okay so we're going to say that the you
you want me to keep it as the committee
or do you want to if representatives of
the committee Mr chair I've understood
you to say that Mr Olsen will attend
this Committee in February and I or
March and I wonder if number six would
be better reading that Council notes the
committee will meet with the audit
director to discuss the issues outlined
in his later
reporting account and then it then
reflects that you are asking him to
otherwise I think it's wide open to
interpretation as to whether the whole
committee is going to meet with audit
New Zealand
Tom's going to hit his hand up first but
he'll be wanting to a comment on number
six Au uh Navi in terms of its form
well no I just want to clarify two
things
um I don't know why we're negotiating
with Derek going forward I mean I don't
trust a guy for him to throw this letter
and throw it into that available to the
media as well it discreets us
he gave
Finance Assurance he gave me Assurance
he's been talking to you yeah yeah it's
all been done and it doesn't happen and
we and we sit back here and say oh well
it'll be done in February well will it
be done in February
okay the next issue
um and so I I just I've got zero times
for this going forward so um you know
I've got to make some decisions about
where I take this because I mean it just
can't sit here talking to Derek anymore
right I mean why isn't the guy zooming
in today
because
I'm sorry he's not zooming today because
I didn't invite him oh okay
um and okay that's a combination of
actually there was a little there was
limited Point sure because we need to
actually sit down properly face to face
and literally he for good reasons family
reasons in South Africa yeah but look
Sonic sorry sorry for going on about
this but I just need to flesh it out
look we sat with him this time last year
yeah and had this same conversation
about his resourcing and his time
Framing and us being north to south and
being the last cab off the rank when it
comes to getting what it's done it's not
good enough
um and you just don't keep telling the
same person it's not good enough okay
Bobby I think we just repeating what
we've already agreed in the conversation
the question is have I got emotion here
that is going to be satisfactory meet
the uh the intent of the committee Tom
you had a point sorry and maybe it just
strengthens a little bit the you know
the purpose of the meeting
um
I I mean I I think that we should be
actively exploring whether we can follow
the example of other councils
here in this region
um and move away from Modern New Zealand
I mean I have been on I'm going to tell
you a few boards new have and had this
exact conversation
it's always been a difficult process but
they've always managed to achieve it and
and move away from other New Zealand and
move to a private provider for the
simple reason that audit New Zealand
simply cannot provide the service and
the Very statement that we're lost in
the queue I think
um is almost proof enough as far as I'm
concerned now uh well we can go and and
you can go and and you can you know
discuss videos in New Zealand I I would
like to see part of that discussion even
at the stage
um what would be the process by which we
could move to a private provider
I'm not supposed to do what would be the
process please
the auditor general will always be the
auditor in the cargo City Council
the controller in order to order is our
auditor he or she
points are representative to undertake
the order in this case they've appointed
Board of New Zealand so technically what
we would be asking
would be for the auditor general to
consider appointing a different
audit provider
and that's what's been achieved
elsewhere if there have been changes in
India provider whether that's away from
audit New Zealand or whether that's
bringing all of New Zealand and over
over another provider Tom so that's just
technically the correct the correct way
to deal with it I think the important
Point here is under number five we are
wanting to talk to the office of the
auditor general as well as audit New
Zealand so this goes back to the point
who do we want to talk to and it goes
back to your point ring and we want to
talk to the owner
okay so that's what we're trying to do
here is engage with both audit New
Zealand and the office of the auditor
general
on actually our concerns
and it's going to have to follow two
things one one I suspect we need to have
that time to sit down with the two audit
directors Chris Janae who does City
Holdings along with Derek Olsen who does
ICC and we need to meet over these two
letters
but then I suspect out of that they will
need to be a discussion in the way that
you're already indicating with me was
the oag okay so that is going to be the
important uh Claire has quite rightly
said Navi you should also cosign number
five
okay so it's just not me and Ross it's
you as well I think Tom race is an
important issue that in N5 we should
also have written into that that we want
to discuss with the order of the general
the issue of who provides the elements
right I think some are suggested we
should have a bit more of a team look
putting the finest people beside me here
and with Derek's not going to achieve
anything it'll just be a slinging match
so if we were to add to that um uh um
that the mayor independent chair and
member respond to the Museum of AG with
the committee's concerns regarding the
leather and management response and uh
and future
audit yeah sorry future providers and no
I'm kind of yeah you should have Beast
right at the start
and um who should provide the audit
going for it sure picture order
petitions sorry the future order version
thank you appreciate that
um
right I think we've got a reasonably
fashioned to see any other comedy effect
would like to raise on on the interview
for your health clear on on these
resolutions
just the last one which is that when you
say order directly you're talking about
Derek yes
I don't see any value I think we passed
that point I think I'm back I think I'm
back now I think I think I think I'm
back to my point that In fairness to you
know he has fired his shots we've got
that letter we've got a response from
there we need to sit down around the
table and discuss and thrash that out I
mean there are challenges that he is
saying about us
which we need to think through
um we'll be at that in the in the way
the balance certainly in the
conversation today we fully we're on
pretty Solid Ground relative to what
Derek has said but we need to have that
thrashed out yes I guess what I'm
suggesting is look we're already
committed to February March
um any discussion we have with him
between now and then we'll just go back
over the same stuff
um it's not going to change the next
year's audit which is what we really
want is we want to get this one
completed and have a better process this
time right first up tying these guys up
in the next couple of months and work
with a session with Derek I think
achieves
I mean you've been meeting with him meet
with him monthly
and this later came as a surprise to you
became a surprise my camera is blind
side bloody and more weakness Mr chair I
just remind the committee that Derek
will need to attend for the signing of
the end or the presentation of the
annual report and I would fully expect
that somebody around the table will
raise these issues with them so I think
that all you're doing with this
resolution is is
um signaling to everyone including Derek
but there may be that discussion
yes Ross in terms of pro process 0.6
will proceed 0.5 I think it does I think
that's a very helpful I mean we would
have changed it around it gets the order
that gets the order right thank you Ross
it's a good point
right I'm prepared to move this from the
chair do I have a circular thank you
Ross there's any discussion on the
motion
there's not I'd like to put it in please
all those in favor please say aye those
against
that's Carrie thank you very much
um
yes okay so look can I just walk could I
just move the procedural motion that we
go into PX
um for the reasons that are stated and
then I propose we take a short break
when we come back we'll be already MPX
um so if we go next you can find a page
three you realize the two matters are in
front of here I'll move from the chair
that we that we move into PX die every
second day
thank you Darren I'll put the motion all
those in favor please say aye all right
okay let's adjune for five minutes while
the appropriate